Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Sada khajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and Ashana miracula award click the
link and donate what you can slam you
believe that the woman has has or should
have equal rights
number equal rights
and that whatever the manga is a woman
gets the same there is a Hadith that
says that what is that the money of the
husband belongs to the moment so that's
an inequality because what that means is
the following for example
a man okay check this out it feels
equality look what Islam how is a woman
a man has to pay for the rent the
shopping the gas the electric gas United
gas bills no no that's not Hadith I'm
saying a man is a maintain a protector
so he has to provide a house he has to
do the shopping council tax all that
this kind of stuff okay he has to pay if
he was equality it has to be 50 50.
we're not being a 50 50. but you discuss
that with this power no you're not
understanding if a man comes to you a
Muslim man and says you have to give 50
to the shopping and rent you say to him
bye-bye you're not a man you're a boy
look
if a man if a man comes to you sister
I'm telling you you're young and wants
to marry you and says you have to pay
half the rent and shopping you say to
that man you know what hijab says you're
a boy you say to him you're a boy we
Allah I need a man
so you'll go 50 50.
no you're not dude look look at this
check this out
that you don't have to
okay look no if you want to
who said it's shame for you to give if
you don't give 50 50. you don't need to
give a penny sister listen to me
carefully
sister we follow Islam not your
subjective morals
34 Allah says the men are the
maintainers and protectors what your
sister
and protect the woman they care for them
maintain means you pay for shopping you
pay for rent you don't pay a penny
my dear sister
sister the Sharia is saying look it's
infiltrated your mind so much that
you're even foregoing your rights you'll
see look
you told me if a man comes to me and
says I said fine okay one second all
right no problem the man comes to me and
says I'll do 100 no no no no no he has
to do you understand
application
it's an obligation yes good now now if
it's 50 50 what if you're pregnant and
have a child and you can't work anymore
and then you come to assist you where's
my 50 50. he's not allowed to say that
I'm saying this for you
this is a celebration in the Bible I can
see they're like oh you're here forgoing
it sister
saying I'm saying that you have the
ability to share no if you want to look
if you if you say you know what I have
mercy on this man I want to help him out
may Allah bless you but you don't have
to he has to make that clear because I
don't want you know some brother some
brother watching this and saying I need
to marry this sister because it's going
to go 50 50. I'm trying to protect you
here sister yeah any of your brothers
are watching here yeah you have to if
you know you're a boy okay I'll make you
very clear he has to provide for you and
protect you no 50 50. not winning a
fight Hey listen you get the first car
I'll get the second no no he has to go
even if he gets knocked out and if the
woman Works how's she going to work if
she's pregnant
she's not remove the pregnancy it's
marriage to stop pregnancy has happened
okay let's say the woman can't get
pregnant okay that's a very that's an
exception to the rule let's talk it
generically so all these women are going
to be 50 50. no way
that the woman's not working in your
example no no no she can her money is
her money yeah yeah when she works
part-time as long as she's not
no no like me personally me personally I
told my wife if she wants to work
part-time that doesn't go against my
rights meaning if she's working long
hours and I come home and I haven't I've
worked the long hours and there's no
food on the table of course I'll be
upset because I've been working you know
I would want food here so if she's like
I've worked I'll say look don't work
I'll work I just I just want my wife at
home so so yes sorry everyone was not
working or fight you just coming home
help yourself what do you mean help
yourself make your own Cruise okay so
let me get this right I'm gonna go work
long hours and I'm gonna come home and
cook for myself come on guys man come on
guys man let's not leave it let's not
live in Disneyland guys it's not
chocolate it's not Charlie in the
Chocolate Factory my dear sister no no
if if look if the situation is where
they both have to work I'm saying a
traditional man and a traditional woman
she wants to stay out home yeah and he
is working okay if they're both working
if they are both working long hours well
of course there has to be some kind of
compromise I'm talking about a
traditional man that's providing for the
husband the wife and the wife is at home
I mean the best thing that you minimum
you'll accept is I would appreciate nice
food that's it and I think no
traditional woman has a problem with
that
what he's talking about is sadly the
society we live in today
tradition you're you're using the
example of tradition not traditional men
one traditional women
traditional men want traditional woman
but that's your one no no not my one
this is what men want even on Instagram
generally always thought exceptions
don't make the rule I'm telling you
generally a man does not like a woman
who has a past in the context she sleeps
she slept around a traditional man
wouldn't want that a traditional woman
would want a man who can provide protect
and is a leader and makes certain
decisions that's what a woman was due to
a hypergamous nature so I'm saying that
a man has certain rules a woman expects
and a woman has certain criteria man
experience as simple as that
okay let's go to the idea of like making
food and cooking yes yeah the man
expects that but like does the woman
want that does the woman
okay does the man want to go work longer
hours for her
so then why is he doing it talk about it
and switch no no no this is the problem
why do I need to switch roles
does it say a woman has to cook and
clean and and what is this what I'm
saying look look check this out let's
check this out a man goes and works no
questions asked 12-hour shift man works
for his family does this so he can
support his family in the future no one
bats tonight the moment he says I want
food y'all uh how could you ask for food
oh my gosh
well why this is Injustice well lie can
you imagine okay okay you know what you
know what I've been dealing with this
would you would you would you want a man
who tells you to go work and he cooks
don't do that no way
no way women are women are hypergamous
by their nature and if you was working
you know what you do you replace that
man like that because you weren't a man
who provides and protects can you
imagine you're going working and then
when she have an argument check this out
check this out sister I'm telling you
how a male men are traditional men who
have Traditional Values and within our
fittler we want to protect and provide
you know why
look does any of the sisters you have
children
if anyone has kids no okay a woman does
she love the fact that she can provide
for her baby is that something maternal
yes she loves it as men we love the fact
that we can provide for our wives we
love it the moment the moment it's just
at the moment the moment
a a woman says no I'll go work etc guess
what you know when you have an argument
and the wife you know our sisters their
tongues are like razor they slice you
yeah imagine she comes and says I
provide for this house
is going to punching him in the face
imagine your wife coming and saying who
pays the shopping who pays the rent and
he's there like a machine yeah yeah you
do yeah
myself you know why because let me tell
you yeah
I have this discussion with my wife and
my wife says well lie I've never seen my
wife more happy in the house with the
kids voila she loves it
I sometimes say to her you know I say to
him sometimes I sometimes say to her if
you want a part-time job we're gonna go
get a part time before you not for me no
she's like I'm happy I'm happy feminism
has destroyed women you know why boss
baby
sister sister sister
my dear sister you should be the leader
my dear sister
do you want to be the leader
only a man who's a simp will say yes to
that a man who is a real man would not
come and say I'm going to marry you
you're going to be the leader you're
going to pay for the rent while he's a
boy what does hijab say boy you're a boy
you're a boy a man who provides a woman
is hypergamous by her nature that's why
if you look at studies woman dates
across and up meaning a woman's
expectation to a man he has to be some
kind of a man that looks like a man go
and look at her studies bro ask any
sister would you marry a guy who's this
tall
can you walk next can you imagine hey
it's a nature we don't blame her she
wants a man who's taller a study show
you know what was their criteria six
foot four probably doesn't even
exists
no that sister that is how woman now we
accept him how they are you don't accept
us how we are
acceptable okay men okay men want to be
leaders men want to be protected men
want to be providers men want to be the
main source of the house
so you're saying I want to be the leader
I'm not saying our first Filipino leader
good so I'm saying that I can also lead
myself sometimes of course you can do
yourself you said College yourself no
but no no I know I know but a man in his
nature he wants an obedient wife now
what does obedience to me when I say
this sisters are like oh what's this guy
talking about now I was agreeing with
him up to now
obedience meaning it doesn't mean I'll
come and get a stick and slap ahead
tongue and they make me lasagna you know
bang this was too salty I'm not talking
about that yeah is that some sort of
obedience is that for example obviously
loyalty Etc the man is the man is a
leader he makes decisions like for
example
in my household sometimes I'll plan the
day we're going to do my wife will come
and say you know what instead of going
there let's go here I've got us a
banging idea before that let's go let's
do it it's
on demand bro how you how you how dare
you come and tell me where to go I'm not
talking about that I'm talking I feel
like the man in the house yeah and
that's why men most of the times when a
married woman are hot headed brother I'm
a man and I see masculine chasing her
you point me off but I want feminine
your femininity well life should tell
you something if a woman explored a
femininity will lie a man you can do
anything with a man you don't like a
puppet yeah because your femininity is
your most strongest thing and guess what
the man's biggest desire is what our
sexual urges which we're talking about
sexual study studies and man sexual urge
is not compared to a woman so meaning
sisters if you capitalize on your
femininity well Allah you got the man on
your finger you come around your finger
but sisters think the more manly I
become a boss baby and this time won't
let you putting me off you're moving
like a man I didn't marry a man
sometimes men use use their leadership
and their masculinity to an advantage to
control women okay that's the main
problem okay good point they say in the
name of Islam this is what Allah wants
me to do and that is give me an example
let's be more specific because that's
gonna be that can be like
why is it that they do they uh oppress
people think of something
okay let's not go personal because
there's cameras let's not go personal
yeah okay this okay this is very
interesting because these things might
stem from them yeah so
anyone that's recording this bloody
sister's face yeah okay blur her face
okay
anyone that doesn't blow her face I'm
gonna send a strap to the channel yeah
okay no no but it's very important
because you know sometimes we talk to
people and we use logical arguments it's
actually something pertaining to
something that's happening be their
husband brother or father yeah okay so
sometimes what happens with our sisters
is when we say I want a woman that's
obedient they think oh my dad you used
to abuse my mom and beat her up black
and blue we're not talking about that
man we are not talking about that man
generalized
you understand about men no no but
that's facts I'm talking about men okay
yes but there's a fact generally I'm
giving fantasy generalization
yes yes
sister sister for example
I'll give you another generalization
yeah
something
okay most women are shorter than men
most men are stronger than women that's
a fact it's a fact that your over
General is a generalization what you're
seeing first no next
but there's exceptions to the rule there
are women that can knock out a man
that's exceptional but exceptions don't
make the rule yeah so what I'm saying is
men no no man no man would ever say I
want my husband and my wife to lead I
want my wife to be boss babe
if my wife was a dustman collector she
was on the Rosco lesson while life it
don't mean nothing to me a man judges a
Woman by her past and a woman judges a
man by his future so he looks at a man
he's like okay what's he doing for
himself
someone's sinful Hearts but this is
where I'm saying you need to understand
a man's psychology for a man a woman's
past look this is done by non-muslim
forget Muslim men yeah Muslim men men
there was a question as I saw a YouTube
video yeah they said you know what they
say to the man would you rather have 50
000 pounds in debt or that your
girlfriend has got 50 bodies you say 50
000 pounds in debt
but the man needs to walk on his
way he's created no should I tell you
okay you know what you know what
convert to Islam that's fine
let me make something clear I'm not
seeing a sister with a past he's
repented cannot ask for a man who I'm
not saying that let's make that clear
okay ignore him okay please Aki bro
ignore him go speak to a tree is better
it has more benefits yeah yeah yeah okay
please a big ignore him he gets excited
yeah what I'm saying is if a woman has
repented that's fine I'm not seeing her
past I'm not seeing you judging by your
past you get it a woman who's repented
has a right to ask for a virgin guy but
what I'm saying is in a man's psychology
yes he does not want a woman who's been
around
foreign
you might be lying but the thing is
that's what we say to it but this is the
man's psychology system I'm trying to
say we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah in the
country of Norway click on the link and
donate now for the sake of Allah